Speaker 2: OK. It is.
Speaker 1: I don't know that
I can say it officially the 2022 midterms
right now, but at least in the context of
the former President Donald Trump jumping
Speaker 2: in full steam ahead
on the 2022 midterms, things are
Speaker 1: getting going. Donald
Trump has added another endorsement. This
is an extremely polarizing endorsement. This
is exactly the type of endorsement
we were waiting for of an incumbent
lunatic Trumpian Republican to show us.
Yes, Trump's going to be involved. Donald
Trump has now endorsed radical
Speaker 2: lunatic extremist,
Speaker 1: disgusting Republican congresswoman
from Colorado Lauren Boebert or Lauren Boebert,
as Ro Khanna called her. I kind of liked when Ro
Speaker 2: said, Congresswoman
Speaker 1: Boebert sounds like
a completely different person.
Donald Trump putting out this endorsement laced
with erratic capitalization, which I will mention
endorsement of Congresswoman Lauren Boebert.
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert has done a fantastic
job in her first term, representing Colorado's 3rd
District. I can't think of anything she's done,
but OK. She is a fearless leader, a defender of
Speaker 2: the capitalized
Speaker 1: America First agenda and a fighter
against the Capitol. L loser RINOs and Capitol
are radical Capitol, the Democrats. She will
continue to be tough on Capitol, see crime
Speaker 2: strong on Capitol,
Speaker 1: be borders and always protect our under
siege Second Amendment. Lauren has my capital see
complete and capital t total capital e endorsement
for her reelection. Why the random capitalization?
We still don't know. Someone wrote to me and said,
Oh, you know, Trump is German and in
German you have capitalized nouns.
Speaker 2: And that's not what
Speaker 1: Trump is doing, guys. I can assure
you Trump has no idea what's going on in Germany.
So what's interesting about this, OK? We suspected
Trump was going to be very involved in 2022, and
he's getting involved right now. Lauren Boebert
has actually said she has already asked
Speaker 2: Donald Trump to go
to her district and do a rally
Speaker 1: for her if Trump gets involved to
that level. It is going to be quite a midterm and
indeed, I think it is going to be quite a midterm.
Also, the choice of this district is interesting
because let's be frank, this is a very easy race
and Trump is big on his record.
Speaker 2: Now he lies about
Speaker 1: his endorsement record. Trump
has previously said he's like, You know,
what do you say? One hundred and fifty and one
or something? His record is actually not that
good. He mostly endorses incumbents, and still,
I think he only had like a 60 something percent
success record with endorsements. But
this is a really easy one if you want
to put points on the board and then use those
points to justify running yourself in 2024.
No Democrat
Speaker 2: has been
Speaker 1: the representative for Colorado's
3rd District since 2008. That was John Salazar.
If you go before 2008 and remember, the
elections are every two years in the
house. If you go before 2008, you've got to go
back to 1992 for the the last Democrat to hold
that seat. So in other words, since 1992. One
Democrat has held Third District of Colorado,
and it's otherwise all Republicans. You look
at the demographics, it's 65 percent rural,
very favorable to Republicans. It's 71
Speaker 2: percent white,
Speaker 1: pretty favorable to two Republicans,
although not not as crazy skewed as some other
districts. It is considered in the Cook
Political Report Political Values Index,
a Republican plus six race. And when you
Speaker 2: consider other factors,
including the power
Speaker 1: of incumbency,
that's a pretty solid Republican seat. So one
of the things we will be paying attention to is,
OK, Trump's going to be involved. He's going to
be doing endorsements. Is he disproportionately
doing them in the safest of safe districts?
He is endorsing some challengers, but is
Speaker 2: he mostly endorsing
Speaker 1: incumbents? All of this
is stuff that we're going to follow.
Speaker 2: But no one, it's clear he
Speaker 1: wants to be involved and number two.
These Trumpian races may very much influence
what the Republican Party decides to do in 2024
and whether Donald Trump will even run. Earlier
this week, we interviewed Michael Cohen, Michael
Cohen said. Donald's not running in 2004, and he's
not running because he can't afford the hit to his
ego to lose again. The counter would be, and it's
not about who's right or wrong. There's no right
or wrong yet because it hasn't happened. They're
just predictions. The counter would be Trump
ends up believing he can easily win everything.
Speaker 2: And so that
Speaker 1: may be a factor in him deciding to
run. But step one is we don't even have to worry
about 24. We're going to look at Trump's record in
twenty two. We'll look at how he's welcomed in
Speaker 2: twenty two and we'll look at how
Speaker 1: involved he gets.
So this is the first one.
Speaker 2: Let me know who you think
Speaker 1: he will endorse
next. We will have more on the endorsements
and the 2022 campaign on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.
Speaker 2: You can also
Speaker 1: find me on Instagram
Speaker 2: at David
Speaker 1: Pakman. We'll take a quick
break and be back with much more.